well one person who knows all about
being caught out by last minute changes
to quarantine rules is the transport
secretary grant chaps and he's with us
now hello to you good morning because of
course you had to
can your spanish holiday the day after
you got there that's right i did it to
myself i got to spain and then had to
put
spain in quarantine and leave my family
holding and come home so i'm
very aware of what people are going
through albeit that there aren't any
english changes
this week so what wonders what how these
decisions are being made because
to all intents and purposes everybody in
england and northern ireland thought
that they wouldn't be able to travel
back
from portugal so so a lot of people
invested quite a lot of money on early
flights those
flights have been hiked and they can why
have you decided that england and
northern ireland
is still open on the corridor as well as
in scotland it's a bit like the
decisions on
the lockdowns and the way the rules are
being applied throughout the different
parts of the
united kingdom throughout the the
coronavirus so you're quite accustomed
to seeing for example
scotland do one thing and say you can
meet with so many people in wales to
another and so on and so forth
and actually the travel corridors are
similar to that
and i do realize it creates confusion um
for people
not to have a single rule but we do have
this devolved
approach throughout the united kingdom
and i can only be responsible
for the english part of that so why have
we decided what we've decided
so we all get data from the joint
biosecurity
center and they look at it and they use
a number of different
measures so it's not just the number of
cases per 100 000
that counts but also the positivity rate
how many of those cases are
testing positive and also how the um the
government in that country
is dealing with it whether it's a local
outbreak and many other factors all of
which i've tweeted about for anyone
who's interested
um and um using that information we're
able to come to
a conclusion um one of the things about
using only a rate per 100 000 of course
is if a country does the right thing
and does a lot of testing then it
suddenly finds that it is
excluded if you only use that rate so
you must look at other factors
and that's what i've done that's what
we've done here and this week as i say
it's led to no changes
partly because the test positivity for
example in portugal
actually came down on the last set of
figures uh when we were making this
uh choice uh and also on greece the
overall numbers had come down so
this wasn't one-way traffic this week so
you talked about localized issues there
forgive me
so uh wales and scotland have a
different decision to england and
northern ireland why don't we then
do the why don't we separate portugal
from
uh the azores or madeira or uh spain
from the balearic islands so i think the
canary island yeah i think there is an
argument for
sort of regionalizing it if if you like
um
but uh having said that and i know there
was a big fuss about this at the time
because i was in spain and had to send
my had to quarantine myself and send
myself
home and people said well the islands
are fine actually the islands now
wouldn't be
um fine um so often you do find this
this crossover but it is fluid and i do
accept that there is space to look at
those types of so you are going to look
at that one of the reasons we didn't
earlier though
is we didn't have the level of
information that the joint biosecurity
center
is now starting to process so for
example they've got to be certain
that they can rely on the test data on
an island which might be a relatively
small island and may not have or
in the earlier days of the corona virus
earlier in the summer may not have had
the level of detail that we would need
to assess that country so
that's why we haven't been able to rush
to doing islands separately
but there's a massive landmass in the
united states of america
how can you possibly judge i don't know
california and texas
and places like south carolina with
wisconsin they don't have the same
issues
and if we don't sort that out the
airline industry is corporate
it's certainly true on a big landmass
like that there are lots of
variations on the other hand it's
relatively straightforward to travel
between one place
and another and the overall level
so not just in the hot spots but the
overall level in the united states for
example there's 88 cases when i last
looked per 100
um we're on about 14 cases so you can
see that there's an overall higher risk
and of course people can very easily
travel from one place to another
to pick up a flight and that would be a
problem but there's a bigger problem
actually i'll just point this out with
the united states secretary it's very
easy
to go from bristol to cardiff yes no
that's true but we have in the united
kingdom the ability to do
an enormous amount of uh testing so our
testing is now
you know per population bigger than
germany bigger than france and so on and
so forth we don't have that capacity in
the united states but i was going to say
kayla's
there's one other thing about the united
states which is the administration there
doesn't allow uk passport holders to fly
there were europeans to fly there at the
moment so
you know there is a
their principle is not allowing people
in and actually interestingly they did
that very early on
and we saw it didn't help them with the
number of cases that they end up
developing the daily telegraph will be
speaking to their travel editor shortly
they
suggested airport testing is the way
forward why do we not just do it yeah
i know that airport testing is one of
these things that sounds
so logical you you come in you get a
test perhaps one of these very quick
tests
and you go off and you're free not to
quarantine the problem that we have and
this is what i'm working with
airports on at the moment in the
industry is that a day
zero test as you get home is unlikely to
find the vast majority of people who've
traveled with coronavirus
but are asymptomatic in other words you
don't know and you shouldn't be
traveling if you do think you've got
coronavirus of course
so you don't know that you've got it
you're tested on day zero there are
arguments about this
but public health england say that would
perhaps pick up just seven percent of
people who are in fact positive and
allow those people to sort of go
off so you probably have to have some
kind of quarantine period in here
perhaps seven or eight days maybe a test
then but these are the things that we're
working through
at the moment and how does that differ
from people in in general society who
have one of these tests they don't have
to quarantine so of course somebody in
general society
want to come back from a country with a
higher level of coronavirus which is the
thing
that we're trying to protect against so
if you went back to
what if you went i've also talked about
it being regional within those areas
but if you go back to the examples of um
spain i think off top of my head 130
cases per 100 000 as opposed to off
um 14. um so you could see that somebody
coming back from spain you wouldn't want
them to be
as you put it sort of wandering around
in general society until they've been
able to have a test that
shows that they're negative or as is the
case at the moment
have quarantined as i had to do for
those 14 days
so it's not that we don't want to do
these things and i hear the calls from
the airports and i spoke last night to
you know john holland kaye who's the the
boss of heathrow airport and
many others it's not that we're ignoring
the great work they're doing on trialing
out tests
but i've spoken to my opposite number
for example my my french opposite number
they did put testing in
but of course came you know have
realized some of the same things which
isn't actually the silver bullet
solution to this
what you've got to do is be able to test
further down the line with a period of
quarantine as well
i'm afraid this coronavirus is just not
simple to you know
navigate around and we have to do our
best and
with that is what we're doing okay i
want to ask you about hs2 but first let
me ask you while we're talking about the
aviation industry
what's all this about your private plane
being registered in the u.s i saw this
story
well i've been a i've been an aviator
for a qualified pilot for
25 years and i've flown planes on on the
british
register and the american register but
if you fly a plane on the american
register it still has to be maintained
by british engineers
the main thing people say on the u.s
register is it's permissible
to do some of the engineering yourself
well i have to say that's something that
i've never
personally attempted yeah so why bother
registering
i didn't it's it's like if you if you
got a car and it was on a french
uh plate would you change the plate that
that's all it was so you're not
undermining the rules at all
i've never i've never registered the uh
uh uh the aircraft on any
uh register at all so now okay um talk
to me about hs2 then
um you are announcing the formal start
of the construction
on hs2 um hasn't it started already
there's been lots of preparatory
work over the years and um but this now
is the first
time after three years where there's
sort of spades in the ground
building the actual thing itself and
it's a good news story i know it's been
a very controversial
project to get hs2 up and running it's a
good news story because
this is the start of 22 000
jobs that will be created over the next
few years um helping to build that first
phase that's from london to birmingham
and then of course it goes up to
manchester leeds and
you know we'll make journey times right
up to scotland a lot faster as well so
so good news today and particularly the
time when the economy needs that boost
okay let's talk about um tony abbott do
you think
that your colleague the health secretary
misspoke yesterday when he said that
what he actually said was what the what
he inferred was that uh because
he was good at trade we could forgive
his antecedents
i didn't see the uh of course you did he
did six million views on
do you want to see it sorry absolutely
i'm sure you don't support some of his
comments he's a homophobe
and he's a misogynist well uh
he's also an expert in uh trade
so that's all right then well look i i
as far as i'm aware there haven't been
any announcements made on this at all so
i think we should wait till we
um get an announcement one way i'm
asking you about
tony abbott and whether you feel that
your colleague misspoke when he said
that it was okay
for him to be a misogynist and a
homophobe reportedly
because he's good at trade well as i say
i i don't want to sort of get in
something where i haven't
he hasn't been announced as whatever
this trade position is
um i haven't studied the tony abbott
record that's the first time i've seen
matt hancock um talk about it so i know
these things get sort of
blown up and sometimes sort of you know
become a very big kind of issue here but
if if if he hasn't been announced and uh
you know i haven't personally seen all
of his
comments personally speaking you know i
don't think in in
uh you know modern society i think
people
should respect each other and i don't
think um we um
you know i think we we know that the
standards by which we would
you know have conversations but um you
know you're inviting me on something
which i'm
afraid i'm not a worldview shouldn't you
be i mean if he's going to be
representing us
um around the world well and that's the
big question if he's going to be so why
don't we wait
well don't we need to know i'll come
back i will come back i'm sure you will
but i've got you here now so i'm going
to press you if i may
um he may be given that he is a climate
change denial
given that he has said some despicable
things about
the elderly and it didn't matter if they
died of covenant 19 they should die
naturally
given that he talked about women and
ironing
and um some of the views on whether they
should succumb to um
sex or not and given some of the views
he said about
her homer football that basically
homophobic views would you be happy to
have a drink with that man
well as i say i mean you're inviting me
to sort of comment on somebody who
because i wouldn't be happy to have a
drink with him would you well i've never
been invited to have a drink without
don't think of everyone what if you did
would you accept well i prefer first of
all i want to check the rep of myself
i'm afraid i
have to admit i haven't had time to to
to do that and secondly
i i hate to bring us back to reality he
hasn't been appointed to anything and as
far as
there haven't been any appointments made
so let's wait and see i promise i'll
come back on your program
i'm never shy of coming on your program
i'll come back and talk about it if it's
actually interesting and you don't feel
that you're dodging that question well i
simply you know you're asking me things
uh which are very abstract in as much as
nobody's been appointed to the position
so but he's certainly being considered
and
he pretty patel was courting him we saw
pictures of her with him
and liz truss is also very keen on him
taking up the role well i don't think
that somebody's with the fact that
somebody's met
somebody's is is proves that somebody's
posing for photographs in the home
office
well as i say i'm not sure that actually
proves anything apart from the fact he
you know is was a world leader of uh uh
you know a major economy and
and uh and uh economic and social friend
of ours in
australia but uh yeah i know you're
trying to draw me out on this i promise
i will come back
as i said to your colleague yesterday
you know you're a forward-thinking 21st
century man do you really want to be
associated with some of this kind of
well
as i say there are lots of people with
whom their comments i would uh
veermently disagree but i'm not into
defending people who are not actually
carrying out any role for the
british government there's no reason for
me to comment on it until or unless and
i promise you
i'll be back in your studio